you know the Shia's belief about there's
a Hadith in their books and also Cafe if
you do much at once you'll be with
Hussein twice with Hassan three times
with Ali four times with the nebula
Switzerland that's this Hadith in their
books you know so my question to Shia do
you narrate this Hadith to your sisters
and your daughters and your mothers as a
recommendation for them to because all
of us want to be with the message of
Allah so if you're gonna start writing a
comment insulting us therefore you know
much disgusting okay now to do it yeah
because you believe is a bad like now I
always advise my my daughters to do the
about that if you because you you love
yourself to be with the neighborhood so
according to your Deen there's easy way
for you and for your mothers and sisters
and daughters to be with the
neighborhood it's just due to do foreign
so do you go to your mother to listen or
to your sister don't get angry with me
I'm just narrating where it's in your
book so please answer the comment
section
is
not marriage with the intention of
divorce when the woman she said listen
you don't have to pay for me even that
subscribe to accept it okay so please
do you advise you sisters your daughters
because that's what you did